halloween is upon us people we're gonna
watch
call of duty black ops cold war zombies
excited to check this trailer out we're
gonna watch just the trailer then we'll
talk about it a little bit afterwards
let's do this people
pam what have you done did you get the
package
watch it watch the tape
what the hell is that
what's happening again
[Music]
five nights at freddy's
[Music]
it's like the headshot movie it's like
overlord
those are some bright zombies
[Music]
okay whoa
this feels so metal
it's like metal and radioactive and
sci-fi
dude
[Applause]
whoa
it's going like full resident evil no
bit of a doom vibe too yeah
so many sweeping shots i know elemental
pops
i want it i want it
great great great stinger at the end
yeah
well you know you got to have that
patent military confidence
i think it looks awesome i think it
looks like a lot
a lot of fun engaging with call of duty
fans
can be uh quite a challenge you
sometimes feel like you have to have
real
thick skin as if you're in a war with
these people that's true
it's like going through a boot camp all
right let's get ready to have a
fight over nothing that's really that
important
this imaginary experience but looking at
the zombies here i can imagine that
it'll be like a good amount of people
who might be a little bit let down and
then i
imagine that there'll be a good amount
of people who are pretty excited for
this we did uh hear some of the
information
in between watching the trailer and then
going back here to talk about it because
we wanted to get a little bit more info
about the video game they said they
would let you spawn
don't have to start off with just a
pistol oh yeah yeah
you can basically like choose whatever
weapons you want it seems like they're
really leaning into like
customization and letting you just have
fun from the jump and not trying to make
it like some kind of game you gotta
build up to
i have a feeling though that purists
they're gonna want to start off with a
pistol though
so you gotta you're gonna have a bunch
of people go to the main menu and select
pistol only that's what you do
i only play call of duty when i go over
to my friend's place and then he always
has a new call of duty so we just game
it up all the time i don't really
engage heavily into uh the storyline so
much
you know i'm one of those people who
just likes to play for fun i suck at it
i'm really bad and then when i do good i
get insanely cocky
that's just my playing style it upsets
everyone around me
and they always leave the room but hey
don't hate the player
it decays the game that's exactly what
that phrase is for
yeah i love the how the game feels
familiar
feels kind of like classical gameplay
with call of duty yet there's something
about its tone
it's vibe that feels overall very fresh
and i i think too you know that for
coming things come out november
yeah which is a weird release date i
mean right after halloween i feel i
get it for the holiday season you want
to get gifts
right after the election you'll just
want to
kill i just think you know um
didn't overlord come out it's not the
same thing at all
call dude is one of those franchises
that even if there's a fan base of
a section of it that's like oh i don't
like this they're still gonna buy it
anyway
it's gonna make me a gazillion dollars
regardless of when it comes out i just
feel like this would be a really cool
release before halloween right yeah
seems like the ideal time or at least
in the lead up to halloween and on
halloween i mean at at very least like
drop it on halloween maybe
yeah yeah you know or something like
that because this does look like a
perfect
you know spooky experience and yeah i
mean from looking at the other call of
duty trailers
for zombies this one does at least feel
like a bigger event and more
cinematic or something like that because
you know the other ones have always felt
to me like they they blend call of duty
with a zombie game whereas this felt
like every zombie game at some point
yeah to me but i do like the idea of
like yeah we're starting up a new story
and we are you know taking
elements of the past canon because you
know just i feel like anybody
right now needs to just establish a
canon because that's a thing we expect
but yeah just having like okay you'll
have echoes from the past for people who
played the previous ones but if you want
to just jump in
it seems like you have the utmost level
of customization so if you want to be a
purist you can if you want to be just a
noob you can
um but yeah i just love the scope and
imagination and it was fun to
occasionally remind myself like oh it's
not that hard to do these like crazy
wonder shots when it's all just cg
because i was sitting here going like oh
this is kind of like a movie trailer and
some of those shots did look really
sweeping and impressive and uh
now i just wonder if if like we're gonna
get a george romero
or a danny uh you know trio or anything
like nod at any point
because that's one of the classic
aspects of this game too that is not you
know at all here and it doesn't seem
altogether appropriate but for me
i would want to see that yeah i feel you
i mean i think this one feels
a little bit wilder and faster than the
other ones too there's something about
this that i just
the con the call of duty has evolved
into something that
is always feels a little bit more
kinetic but i feel like that's kind of
an essential
mood and feeling to have when it comes
to a zombie game
especially one like this this one just
felt like so fast that it's gameplay
yeah doom and i think that is a good
call because a lot of these shots just
felt like there's an
onslaught of creatures and you just
gotta level all of them now
you know and that energy and that also
just that heavy metal
style that was also kind of adorning
certain aspects of this does lend itself
and i love like the alternate cold war
history moment to have this take place
and i
and and i get the impression that if you
want to hop into the story mode that
while it's you know they
i believe that character at the very
beginning is a character from a previous
call of duty game mustache eye patch guy
yeah yeah that's what we'll know him
weaver i think
so yeah he's he's from a previous call
of duty game for the most part this is a
new story a new setting and i think that
if you want to like hop into the actual
storyline this is a great way to get
yourself
introduced into it we'll see i mean
maybe i will
i highly doubt i will probably just just
i just want to see the action
that's what happens but isn't that the
main thing you care about you're not
going to want to play this two weeks
after halloween
there are people who cons who are
absolutely absorbed into the
storytelling but
let's face it if i go to the comments
right now i guarantee you a majority of
them are going to be about the gameplay
and not about the story
right all right guys well what'd you
think of this you excited leave your
thoughts down below subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell and hey i want to give a special
shout out to all the people who are
pledged for deleted takes in bts reward
tier and they get a name call out once a
month
collectively here we go shane williams
darius chair steven mendoza
michael o'hagan sean allen joshua ruiz
body rut road tree
sam castle sj94 andrew barber
lucas romero renardkay justin
martin kayla waters
kenny waters rosie beatty dorotheon066
ruby becky underwood
anja r phillip j smith jr
brianna davidson chen smith
hobby or gomez melanie leblanc
brittany parrell or lovely natalie
chase gardner gregory bullock tiana
haitch eva drastic over kent mcknight
lb
[Music]
[Music]
thomas cj thomas
thank you guys we changed our clothes
probably
that was a lot of names to shout out but
really do appreciate each and every one
of you
for being here for the month of
september hopefully
you stick around for the month of
october and then you decide to stay
around
to at least
november 2023
yeah but then will be canceled oh yeah
and then you'll be
the residual income of your pledge will
help
bail out at least me no john will
survive
look at him i will he'll be great in
prison i will be
well appreciated in prison
thank you guys for showing us your
support while we're in prison
you